the colts had their rookie mini camp
this weekend let's hear from general
manager chris ballard
on quitty pay their first round draft
pick
couldn't be more excited look i've we've
i've made some pretty easy picks
where you just knew you know when you
pulled the card it was an easy pull and
and pulling the card of quiddy pay was
very easy stands for everything we want
to stand for
um he's in a position of you know that
we all know is important a defensive end
we think we think he's got really big
upside we think he's going to continue
to get better
um and he's going to add to our front
you know now that the colts have carson
wentz and they feel very good about him
that defense has been
improving the offensive line is great
they're just a
team that is just kind of there
right right there's just this what do we
you know and there it feels like they're
so close to popping through and maybe a
guy like quitty pay helps make the
difference carson wentz is going to be a
huge factor
but uh you know chris balor has done a
great job with that team the results
haven't shown themselves by way of
postseason they're still kind of
gathering themselves
after the andrew luck abrupt retirement
in late august of 2019
but i i feel like they're they're
they're closer and closer
not quite to getting back to what they
were in the heyday of peyton manning but
maybe
starting along a path that will get them
to the point of consistent contention
i'm with you i agree with that i mean
you know you know what to the playoffs
this year
right i mean yeah that's right that's
right but even then
even they went to the playoffs to give
the bills everything they can handle and
they're still kind of like
you're kind of like yeah they weren't
really like bleep blinking on the radar
i know what you mean yeah you're right
there was a little bit of that aspect
missing from the
team where we thought like they were a
legit legit like
scary contender but yeah the andrew luck
thing threw a curveball but
at the same time i think you're right
mike i mean the colts
you know like opposite of like the
raiders
i think there's there's a few things to
talk about on their team where you just
go
man that's that's pretty special what
they got there you know first off
they're offensive line
it's special yes i mean carson wentz we
know what he can do when healthy and
things like that
you know the skill position guys pretty
good running get running backs
good i mean defensive line pretty damn
special and now you got a quiddie pay to
come off the edges
really the only issue on their team was
like lack of edge
threat and quitty pay and even their
their second pick
uh odingbo from vanderbilt are
are both edge rushing type of football
players so
they're really rounding out the roster
right mike and i just look at them i'm
with you i look at it and just go
wait this team is really good they're
like
edge super bowl window type of football
team
and now does carson wentz you know with
acquitty pay
kind of put them over the edge to where
we start off early in 2021 going no like
we thought the colts were on the edge of
the super bowl window they're in the
window like they're that kind of team
and i have a feeling we could be saying
that about them you know four or five
weeks into the year
and it is amazing to think how
differently we feel about the cults if
they had
beaten the bills and they did give the
bills everything they could handle and i
wonder whether or not philip rivers
would have stayed around for one more
year i mean there's an alternate history
gurgling around out there involving the
colts but they may be better off long
term
with carson wentz if wentz becomes
again the guy that he was the guy that
he was when frank reich was in
philadelphia
the guy that frank wright believes he
can be that's really the key to this
team
this gamble they've made on carson wentz
the guy we don't think about when we
talk about this trend
of quarterbacks pushing their way out of
situations they don't like because the
eagles didn't really like
it either but once wanted out he got out
and he gets this fresh start and it's
just one of these teams you know the
bills last year
were that team that kind of slapped us
in the face early in the year
and let us know that they were going to
be serious
all i feel like the colts could do that
depending upon
and this is why the schedule is so
important you're right upon the games
you get right out of the break
right out of the gates what what games
can you get that maybe you can get win
win win and build some confidence
with your new quarterback that's going
to be key as well for the course
a key right i mean we've talked about
the last three years the hell with the
whole schedule it's just like let's look
at those first three or four weeks
to what you're talking about to where
can you come out of that going
wait we did some positives and we can
build on it
and now we can go instead of being maybe
one and three or
you know something like that to now it's
panic and it's like one more loss and
it's really panic
uh i'm with you though mike i think
they're one of those teams too like the
bills last year
where yeah you go hey they're playoff
team from last year they're good
but i think they got the the potential
to be pretty damn special when you kind
of break it all down
it's a top 10 defense in football now
they got
a legit difference maker on the edge the
offensive side of the ball
it's always been flirting around the top
ten and doing all of that
and now you got a quarterback who can
stretch the field
like let's not forget about that philip
rivers was good last year
but there was games and moments where
his lack of arm strength and the ability
to
push the ball down the field hurt their
football team
it hurt frank reich and the fact where
he's a master at finding like these 15
and 20 yard completions
with his great game planning and his
creative offense and everything he does
that way
and that was kind of compromised a
little bit because
people knew like man philip rivers he
ain't going to throw it past 35 or 40
yards
and that shrunk the field a little bit
not going to be able to do that with
carson wentz i think it'll make the
offense look a little bit more dangerous
with him at the helm this year you know
it's funny last week eric decosta the
ravens gm told me that the first thing
he looks at when he gets the schedule
the games in december the stretch
run and i think an established team can
do that yeah right
when you're trying to get your bearings
when you're
testing out a quarterback that flamed
out whatever it is when you have a big
change i think the easier the early
season schedule the better chance you
have to get
everyone in the locker room to say okay
i get it i understand why you went to
get carson wentz i understand why you
hired robert salad to be the coach i
understand
why you made zack wilson the second
overall pick and it really does set the
tone for the season if you can get off
to a great start
yup you can become a great team when
maybe you weren't a great team when the
year began so we'll find all that out
wednesday night for every team
where will the soft spots be and some of
them need those soft spots to come early
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights
from nbc sports